with probability one half as well. That's quite straightforward.
In essence, measuring all of the systems is equivalent to measuring
the entire compound system.
If we don't measure all
of the systems however, but instead we just measure
some of the systems, then the situation isn't
quite so immediately clear
restricting our attention once again to the case of just two
systems to see the essence of what's going on in as
simple as setting as possible.
We can ask the following question, suppose that we have two systems, X and Y that are together as a pair
in some particular probabilistic state.
What happens if we measure
just X and we do nothing to Y?
Well, we can answer this question using some basic probability theory.
First, we know that the probability that the measurement
gives a particular outcome has to be given by this formula
that you see right here.
We can think about the probabilities for each of the classical
states of the pair XY as if we did measure both and we sum over all the probabilities
that are consistent with X being in whatever classical state
a we're interested in.
So that's why the sum right here is just over the classical states b of Y.
One way to think about this
formula is that the probability of seeing a particular classical
state of X if we measure it
has to be consistent with the probability of seeing that state if
we had also measured Y, even though we didn't,
that's very natural and intuitive. The probability for a measurement of X to yield a particular outcome can possibly depend on whether or not Y
was also measured
irrespective of the outcome.
So that tells us what
the probabilities are for the different possible
outcomes of the measurement, but what happens to Y or our
knowledge of Y as a result?
The answer is that there still
could exist some uncertainty about the state of Y as a
result of having measured X
and seeing a particular result. And that uncertainty is represented by this formula right here for the conditional probability
that Y is in some particular
classical state b, given that X is in some classical state,
whatever classical state a,
we happen to have measured.
To be precise, the probability that Y is
in some classical state b, given that X is in the classical state a,
is equal to the probability
that X is in a and Y is in b divided by the probability that X
is in the classical state a.
So if we measure X, we're going to see
different classical states with probabilities determined
by this formula right here
and depending on what outcome we get, we may still have some uncertainty about the classical state of Y and
that uncertainty is reflected
by this formula right here.
There's actually a very easy
way to rephrase all of this and to perform calculations
for specific cases using the direct notation
and it goes like this.
We start by writing down the
probabilistic state of XY as a vector like this, and
this is completely general.
The entries are denoted by Pab and these could be any numbers so long as the entire vector
is a probability vector.
We can express cat ab as a
tensor product like you see right here and then we can use the
bilinear of the tensor product
and specifically the fact that it's linear in the second argument to express this vector
as you see right here.
What we're doing is effectively isolating the standard basis vectors
on the left hand side and putting whatever we need
to on the right hand side
to allow that because that's gonna reveal what happens when we
measure the first system X.
Specifically the probability
to get a particular outcome a is the sum over all of the probabilities that appear in the
parenthesis next to cat a.
And conditioned on getting
a particular outcome a, the probability vector that describes whatever uncertainty remains about Y
is the vector that was in
the parentheses next to a.
Except that we have to normalize it to make it a probability vector and that is is to say that
we have to divide that vector
by the sum of the entries in that vector to form a probability vector.
Here by the way, the sum is taken overall
c in gamma rather than b just to use a different variable name so that there won't be any confusion
about the scope of the
variables if you will.
The sums in the numerator
and the denominator should be considered as separate things and we can avoid any chance
of confusion about that
by using different
variables for the two sums.
Here's a quick example to
illustrate how this all works.
Suppose XY is a pair of bits in this probabilistic state right here to understand what happens
when we measure the first bit
and we do nothing to the second, we write the vector as you see right here where cat zero and cat
one in the first position
are isolated just as we
described a few moments ago.
The first possibility is
that the measurement outcome is zero and the probability
of that happening is the sum of the probabilities
inside of the parentheses